what I'm talking about is that in order
to have molecules you have to have atoms
if you have atoms and molecules you can
have cells
if you have cells you can have complex
organisms if you have complex organisms
you can have human beings notice what is
happening here each level of
complexification utilizes the previously
achieved level of novelty to carry the
entire process to yet a higher level of
self-expression that's half of the
inside the other half is to notice that
each Advance into novelty
happens more quickly than the stage that
preceded it
so that you know it took a billion years
for life to leave the oceans
it took 600 million years for Life once
it left the oceans to produce creatures
like you and me
once creatures like you and me existed
it only took half a million years for
them to go to the Moon
do you see each advancing to novelty
occurs more quickly well this isn't in
our age no mere abstraction this is uh
the fabric and feeling of Our Lives
because we can actually feel the
temporal Continuum accelerating we can
hear the Roar of the cataracts at the
end of time
because the culmination of this process
of interdimensional involution doesn't
lie billions or hundreds of millions of
years in the future it lies immediately
ahead in the human future and the reason
I believe this
is because I believe the fact of history
happening on this planet is an
indication that we have come to the
short epochs of Novel ingression what I
mean by that is I got it down to a
shoutable slogan history is the shock
wave of eschatology what that means is
you have biology
you know sexuality transfer of genes
rearing of Young Life Death birth you
you have that and then you have history
as brain size and cognitive processes as
complexify Beyond a certain level but
history only lasts for a moment
and Beyond history there is this
Collective
higher dimensional thing which is the
source of our religious intuitions I
mean we call it God or the Dao or the
transcendental object at the end of time
it throws an enormous flickering Shadow
over ordinary space and time it's like
an attractor
and I believe the acceleration of time
that is a common place of observation
about our own Century indicates that we
are now below the Event Horizon of the
Basin of this kind of an attractor and
that we are being pulled faster and
faster and faster into a confrontation
with hidden dimensions of ourselves and
reality and that this will reach some
kind of excruciating culmination in
Newtonian space shortly after the turn
of the century and the the proliferation
of invention connectivity
drugs human beings ideas are all
indicative of this enormous outpouring
of creativity that immediately precedes
what I call cribbing from Alfred North
Whitehead the concrescence
you see the idea of of ordinary
historians is that history is pushed
from behind
that it's a the unfolding of a of a
series of causally necessary steps that
can be traced back to the beginning I
don't believe this I think history is a
process that is under the influence of
an attractor history is a set of
narrowing options that are being steered
into the future by the presence of an
end point that the system is attempting
to find its way toward
in other words it's rather like
releasing a marble up near the rim of a
bowl you know where the marble will end
up as it loses energy it finds its way
to the point of least energy which is
the bottom of the bowl and the
historical process is like this and by
historical I mean the geology of the
planet which gave way to the biology of
the planet which gave way to the
epigenetic sociology of our species
which gave way to high-tech electronic
culture which is clearly melting down
into some kind of Bio
electronic symbiotic
Global morphology of some sort
information is is climbing a ladder
through higher and higher levels of
material organization until it can
launch itself into a dimension that we
some units of this process can barely
imagine this is why we have art and
religion and poetry to anticipate the
Unspeakable
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]